des légumes des fruits des plantes
aromatiques et des conseils pour
cultiver ces types de produits
l'objectif de cette graine au tec une
vingtaine d'associations ont participé
au village éphémère alternatiba de
vélizy avec comme thème l'autonomie
partage d'expériences et activités
ludiques notamment pour apprendre à
construire un nichoir pour les oiseaux
faut du bois
bien coupé enfin comme il faut dans les
mesures et des clous pour que ça
s'accroche c'est bien c'est surtout pour
les enfants et puis même nous - c'est
c'est très intéressant
je pense que c'est important d'être
sensibilisés à la planète et à ce qu'on
laisse à nos enfants et de les
sensibiliser aussi parce que c'est
finalement qui vont faire l'avenir
le collectif alternatiba bhl
sensibiliser de manière festive aux
enjeux climatiques et sociétaux avec
comme principe des solutions locales aux
dérèglements mondial dans chaque
alternatiba ont choisi ce qui nous
touche le plus alors ça peut être en
ville ça peut être la circulation douce
ça peut être les économies des ders
d'énergie ça peut être le
le solaire le trier ses déchets créé des
recycleries est donc en fait ce qu'on
fait actuellement on demande aux
associations et aux particuliers de nous
dire ce qui les touche le plus
ce qui touche énormément en région
parisienne en fait c'est les
déplacements donc plus de pistes
cyclables c'est aussi beaucoup ça je
pense de partout là les cantines bio
le collectif alternatiba de versailles
prévoit d'organiser un défi zéro déchet
famille sur l'agglomération de
versailles grand parc à partir du mois
de septembre